remembering her childhood makes Mercedes
sad her parents lied to her all her life
only on his deathbed 10 years ago did
her father admit to her what she had
long suspected he and his wife were not
her biological parents they raised me to
be honest and upright and to always tell
the truth but then they did this to me
after they died Mercedes began
researching and found conflicting
documents to birth certificates one from
Malaga and one from Seville and to
baptismal certificates she knows these
documents must be forged
and so the 60 year-old has a devastating
suspicion I think I was stolen when I
was a baby these documents are like
those of other stolen children from the
1930s through the 1990s up to 300,000
children were taken away from their
parents who were told that the children
had died the newborn infants of
political opponents are unwed mothers
were sold to childless couples who
supported Franco
genetic tests have proven that birth
certificates were forged to conceal
these dealings Mari Cruz is convinced
that she too was a victim of such
schemes she gave birth to a premature
baby in Madrid in 1986 days after his
birth the incubator was empty and she
was told her son had died Mari Cruz and
her husband wanted to see their dead
baby and take it they refused to show us
the baby they said it was so deformed
that they didn't want to upset us when
we insisted they asked whether we had
two hundred thousand pesetas for the
burial in the 1980s that was a lot of
money would you see money Nadel Mary
Cruz let herself be intimidated but now
she's looking for her son whom she sure
was stolen from her she works in a
self-help group for other victims
mothers fathers and children an attorney
is representing the victims in court
finally one of the people involved in
this mass crime gynecologist Eduardo
Vela has been accused of child abduction
and document forgery the 85 year old
defendant refuses to give interviews but
in 2010 some victims questioned him with
a hidden camera
he claimed that distressed mothers had
given their children up voluntarily
though there were no documents to show
this the archive with the mothers
documents has been burned
I personally burned the obstetric
records and the parents declarations of
agreement to adoption it just makes me
sick it infuriates me that this man
might die before he's convicted the
attorney says the parents did not agree
to give these children up for adoption
it was a systemic political and business
measure with government and church
complicity this is not the idea of one
doctor alone he needed officials who
knew about and covered up these
irregularities the scandal involves all
of Spain children for money the Justice
Department refuses to comment Mercedes
is tormented by so many questions was
she sold if so then how much did the
couple who adopted her pay for her she
can't imagine that the people who
brought her up with so much love could
have known about the crimes underlying
the adoption I think that they too were
deceived I don't think they acted
maliciously Mercedes has taken a genetic
test and added the result to a database
she hopes to find blood relatives
siblings nieces or nephews maybe even
her biological parents and to learn what
happened to her after her birth